[Music]
eally cuoco and carl cook are legally KZ
squared on Saturday the Big Bang Theory
star walked down the aisle in a stunning
Reem Acra cape and gown complete with
hand-sewn flowers to meet her fiance at
the altar where they exchanged the most
fabulous vows and had their first kiss
as mr. and mrs. Halley's good pal
stylist Brad Goreski documented the
entire celebration on Instagram well
Kaylee's the best meanwhile the 32 year
old actress shared this stunning photo
of the newlyweds
after the ceremony then it was time for
a wardrobe change
Haley shared this second snap of her
sexy reception look at Adashi Shoji lace
long-sleeve v-neck jumpsuit along with
the caption okay
let's party hashtag KC squared on Sunday
the newlyweds paid tribute to each other
with sweet Instagram posts Carl
captioned his gorgeous snap from their
wedding quote I am still processing the
greatest night of my life marrying the
love of my life et caught up with Coco
back in March here's what she teased
about her wedding date deeds let's put
it this way there will be no animals
left behind every animal we have will be
part of it she can be very special very
emotional and all the things that are
important to us of course animals have
been a huge part of the couple's
relationships the two owned dogs horses
and rabbits together
[Music]
[Applause]